[Music]
hey
it's us again yep we're back not even
hungover and nothing no
that was a fun show last night i can't
believe we talked about the [ __ ]
warrens for five hours well we didn't
talk about the warrants for five
challenges
we talked about the warrens for maybe an
hour and a half and the rest of it was
just
like our regular i kind of forgot how
the show went
i think it was fun yeah it was fun right
yeah i thought it was fun i had a good
time
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
audience comments are [ __ ] funny yeah
it was well you know it's like a funny
that's my heck half the show is the [ __ ]
you guys [ __ ] tell me
yeah yeah oracle says nice necklace
jenny thank you
yeah it's hp lovecraft yeah i don't wear
it that much because it hangs
down kind of low and i always have to
like kind of pull it up and it's just
like that
hanging down kind of level yeah
i gotta get you these [ __ ] more like
low-hanging dresses
[Laughter]
get this [ __ ] get those [ __ ] views
up high again
well we'll see how we'll see how it
comes out with my halloween costume
that's supposed to be like
but i i don't know how it's going to fit
got part of my halloween costume man
yeah got those [ __ ] set of dickies
[ __ ] overalls
yeah like coveralls yeah they were like
the deluxe ones [ __ ] with the zippers
and all the pleats
[ __ ] it looked like the ones he was
wearing in the movie yeah that [ __ ]
were like 50 bucks
how are you going to do that how are you
going to do the um the
what what's that word that i forgot what
it was the things on his head
oh the the electrode zealous kg yeah
i saw how they did it it was just
[ __ ] regular
uh electrical wire oh yeah we got a
bunch of that with garage
yeah eye connectors on the end of them
and then they he
he took round um round band-aids and cut
a slit in in them so he could put the
eye connector in there that's all
that's all that was it wasn't a real ekg
well yeah things it was something that
special effects made up
and it just kind of went up into his
hair into his crazy ass yeah
yeah he stood up he had a glove on
yeah and the makeup he had like [ __ ]
red accents underneath his [ __ ] eyes
and his mouth like he was getting ready
to [ __ ] explode
yeah he was exploding you see that was
like that was some oliver stone john
millius type
stuff you know from from the from the
hand you know at the end the woman was
talking about you know you're fighting
back your primal urges
you know and that that was causing the
[ __ ] hand to
you know it's causing him to do [ __ ] but
but was it
or was it psychokinesis was it
poltergeist
you know there was a real [ __ ] hand
running around with roaches on it but
maybe there was
it supposedly came in through the
[ __ ] ventilation ducts
but the out was is that she had released
one of his hands
right so he could have gotten less could
have gotten loose right you know you're
not
i mean i thought i haven't read the book
like i said that it was based on because
we reviewed it a while back and it's
based on a book called the lizards tale
yeah and um i i think from what i know
of the book and
you know i'm assuming uh you know what
they did in the movie
is that it's that was just his
perception
right like that obviously there wasn't
like a supernatural hand like running
around killing people it was just like
that was how he perceived
was it a supernatural force
i don't know i guess it could have been
like i said they left it ambiguous you
see
here's the [ __ ] weird thing is that
that character not gonna go back and see
what his name was i don't remember what
his name was in the movie
to me that's just all michael kane's
michael caine played himself
yeah and all his ones he kind of does
all the time yeah but anyway
he was an artist and he's drawn [ __ ]
basically conan yeah
you know what i mean well during that
time oliver stone was kind of working on
conan
a little bit before that you know so
there's a conan
millius [ __ ] nichian [ __ ]
connection with the philosophy of the
movie i gotta go back and see it again
yeah i want to see it again yeah louis
said i would look awesome as the bride
of frankenstein i actually did think
about doing brighter i have
i have been the bride of frankenstein
before um god
a long time ago like before i met you
even um back in like
the [ __ ] late 90s and it did come out
like really cool and i actually did it
with my own hair
uh which was it looked awesome but then
the next day i was like why did i do
that
because i like teased it like really
super big um and i was gonna do it this
year but then i thought of like
something better
like or you know i thought of something
cool like it was original
that i wanted to do um okay so
let's talk about this horrifying
documentary
that uh just dropped on netflix which is
called
american murder the family next door
now even though i'm like a true crime
junkie i somehow had not heard about
this case
even though um it was all over the news
i guess like back in 2018 when it
happened or 2017 2018 whatever it was
but i hadn't really heard of it or if i
did i just heard of it like very
peripherally and i didn't really know
any of the details
so i would be interested to know like
people that already kind of knew what
happened in the case
um if their perception of the
documentary was different because i was
coming at it from like not really having
any idea
what was gonna happen you know what i'm
saying yeah but the interesting thing
about this
documentary if you don't know it's about
um the colorado case there's this dude
named chris watts
and they his he had a wife named shanann
and he had two daughters who were little
i think they were only like three or
three and four and shenan was pregnant
with their
third child which was a boy
and at some point he decided like he
started [ __ ] around on her with this
woman nicole
like that he worked with she was cute
too yeah i'm gonna chime in
i'm saying she was cute too it's weird
the mystery wife
looked dumb it looked very simple very
similar you know
they were both cute was she was was this
cute woman worth all this trouble
no well um yeah this [ __ ] was crazy
yeah jenny's gonna get into it this is a
cr this was a crazy [ __ ] case yeah
this dude is [ __ ] crazy
and once i found out more details that
jenny told me after i watched the show
because i thought about it i was like
man what was motivating that guy
you know and then once she told me more
about it what she'll probably tell you i
was like
dude the [ __ ] jackal he seemed like
there's something wrong with that dude
yeah he seems like a total
narcissistic sociopath and he also
seemed like
a black hole like he seemed like a void
like there was nobody there like a robot
like there was nobody in there
he came across like that he was a lizard
you know how i was telling you well not
not the david ike lizard people
but i do i have seen some people that
were [ __ ] nuts
and it's like dealing with a lizard it's
like it's not a real person
yeah like they're lacking consciousness
or higher functions
that's what i said i said it seemed like
he doesn't have any inner life like
there's something going on in there like
your npc's
yeah and again he came across kind of
like that very empty eyed and huh
what and just kind of drifting along
yeah just wanted a new girlfriend so he
killed his wife man his kids
and his kids yeah those little babies
yeah it's like
i don't know it's a so the thing about
it so we went into it not knowing
anything about
the case so it's like even though i was
suspecting from the beginning i'm like
well obviously he probably killed her
because that's
you know 90 of the time 95 of the time
something like that it's like it's it's
some very high percentage
like when a woman gets killed like that
it's almost always like their husband
their boyfriend their ex-husband
ex-boyfriend something like that
so i figured it was probably him but
it's like i didn't really know
like because i didn't know the details
so it's like you know so i'm kind of
like watching it
i did like the way uh this was directed
by she was she's a british
director jenny popplewell is her name i
like that they didn't go
the route of like a lot of true crime
documentaries that have like
you know it's just like talking head
interviews like with people
the entire thing it's almost done like a
found footage movie
because there's so much because shanann
the wife she worked for and i don't
think they mentioned this outright in
the documentary but she worked for
a multi-level marketing company and
so she was online like all the time she
was like
you know on facebook and like
documenting like her whole life and her
kids and everything
because that's what so like a lot of
people were just like god that's so
obnoxious like why is she like recording
her whole life but they encourage you to
do that
in multi-level marketing companies
because you are your own brand
you know what i mean so it's like you're
trying to like establish a you know a
personal relationship with like your
clients and whatnot this is probably the
best documented best recorded [ __ ]
murder case i've ever [ __ ] heard
him trying to talk his way out of it him
trying to say i don't know what happened
to her
just everything the [ __ ] neighbors
had [ __ ] footage of [ __ ] in the
truck being in a certain place and him
doing weird stuff every now and then and
they had all their text messages like
all their computer records they had
everything like that it's like a reality
show
that's what i mean it was like a found
footage and i really liked the way they
did that they didn't do any like talking
heads interviews nothing like that it
just
unfolded like through their facebook put
like videos that she had posted
yeah you know body cam footage from the
cops that like came and
when the you know when she disappeared
um you know and they had like all their
text messages back and forth his
interrogation and [ __ ] yeah
i'll tell you what his polygraph this
dude
was so so [ __ ] dumb and so amateurish
thinking that i thought he didn't do it
yeah
i was like he couldn't have done it
because there's no way for him to get
away with this [ __ ] if he did
he doesn't have an alibi if this is
premeditated then why
you know it because this is supposedly a
premeditated murder
but it was like it was like premeditated
by a [ __ ] six-year-old child
i'm not sure how much premeditation he
did like it was premeditated for sure
but i don't know how long he was
planning it or if he had planned to do
it
that particular day or if he just
decided oh well i'm just going to do it
now
he just strangled his [ __ ] wife while
she was sleeping put her in the truck
put the kids in the truck [ __ ] took
him out to the woods strangled the kids
[ __ ]
i think he smothered the kids smothered
the kids and threw him down a little bit
and threw them out like a [ __ ]
oil tanks like got a site where he
worked went back home and pretended like
eddie she didn't know where they were
yeah that's
i don't know where he kicked up cooked
up a [ __ ] plan like that
like oh they'll never think i had
anything to do with it there's no
evidence i'm like what are you doing the
[ __ ] you talking about you're the first
person that is not
the husband is the first person there so
then he did give him a polygraph which
he fails
they come up miserably they come in here
and pressure the [ __ ] out of him and he
yeah i did it he caved oh yeah he goes
yeah i killed her because she killed the
kids so he [ __ ]
put it on her to try to talk his way out
of it and then i'm thinking
thinking to myself i'm like how where
how was this planned how are you gonna
kill your family and then your new
girlfriend not noticed that you
that that the wife and the family are
gone and she's just gonna move up in the
house with you
and it's gonna be okay and the cops will
never [ __ ] wh what world does this
[ __ ] live in
i kind of feel like his thing was
because it's how do you even keep the
girlfriend the girlfriend would like
nah this [ __ ] is not right yeah it's
like why would you want to stay with the
dude it's like yeah killed his [ __ ]
wife and children why are the cops
questions why are the cops
questioning you all the time about your
about your family disappearing
yeah i'll move in i'll move in with you
what kind of [ __ ] world what is this
dude thinking
he's not thankful i don't think he is i
don't think he had much intelligence i
think
all you know it's like i kind of looked
into because i was really interested in
this case
i will say i think the documentary is
very good like i said i really like the
way that
that it's put together um and coming at
it as somebody that didn't really know
anything about this case it was like
really it was like really interesting
and like really compelling how it
unfolded
but i will say that once i got really
interested so i went and like researched
the case
and they left a lot of [ __ ] out yeah one
of the things that really [ __ ]
blew my [ __ ] mind is i'm watching
i'm watching this program and i'm just
it doesn't say so
i'm projecting a motive into him i'm
thinking
well he's trying to get rid of the old
family and get the new girlfriend up in
that nice
brand new beautiful expensive [ __ ]
mansion that he just bought
not really a mansion it's just a large
house yeah and then he's just going to
continue his life
like this and he doesn't want to pay all
that alimony
nope they weren't making any money
anyway they were [ __ ] in debt they
were going to lose that house probably
so what did it what does that mean he
did that [ __ ] for nothing he did it for
nothing
yeah he wasn't protecting any kind of
money or investment or anything
i mean not that that would make it
better but it's like he didn't really
even have
that's that's a rational motive right
he's trying to protect his wealth
and he's going to kill the family all
right that's
something at least this dude wasn't
didn't even do it for that he could have
walked away
from all that he was going to lose that
house and that family anyway yeah so he
all that [ __ ] was for nothing yeah it
was all in his [ __ ] head
all right what lesson do we take from
this
divorce your [ __ ] wife that's all
that's all he had to do is divorce his
wife
yeah he wouldn't be in prison because
you know what i think it is i'm not
entirely sure like i said i'm not in the
dude's head or anything like that
but the more i thought about it and then
i like read some other stuff
about and i read um uh
portions of his like confession because
he did tell somebody that was writing a
book about it later like he kind of told
her everything like everything that had
happened
and i got the impression that
he was one of those dudes like and this
is why i said he's like a sociopath
because he was so
invested in his image
as like you know i'm this good guy
because it
you know shanann she had been married
before her like first husband was like a
piece of [ __ ]
she didn't even want to get into another
relationship because she had been burned
by the first husband
and so i feel like chris
watts was kind of like the kind of
person that was like well
i can't like my image as like the nice
guy the guy i
you know i rescued her we have this
perfect life that's like
all over the internet like we have this
beautiful house we have these beautiful
children
it's like you know she's always talking
about like how happy they are and
everything all their wedding videos and
all that other kind of stuff
and he's like i can't if his image
of himself as that guy was so
important to him that he didn't want to
be
the person that left his family for
another woman yeah
because i so i feel like his image was
more important than his family's lives
were it's ridiculous
he didn't want to be seen as the bad guy
i mean i really think that that was his
sole motivation
because seriously for a long time like
he denied
um he denied like cheating on his wife
yeah
another thing i picked up from the dude
is that he's very beta
his wife was the [ __ ] dominant one in
the relationship well she was the
go-getter she made more money
she you know she did all that he was
kind of [ __ ] beta around her huh what
and i think the [ __ ] really what
motivated him partially is that he was a
coward he couldn't face her
i think that had to do with it coward he
couldn't face her that he was leaving
because she mark says it right there
normally when a dude does some crazy
[ __ ] like this he's
wrapped up financially and there's all
kinds of these [ __ ] strings you know
what i mean
he's trying to protect a [ __ ]
shitload of money or a house or property
mark says it right there that
[ __ ] could have just bounced he
wasn't going to
he could have bounced and divorced her
and the thing about it is that him and
shanann
were i mean shanann was trying to save
the marriage
but i mean she had asked him to go to
counseling she but she knew
that something was wrong she knew that
he was messing around she had suspected
it because he was acting strange
so it's not like i don't think she would
have given him a lot of trouble if they
just said look we should separate
because i think they were talking about
it beforehand when she got killed
um you know when he killed her she had
been staying with like her parents
um in south carolina for like six weeks
so it was almost like a trial separation
so it's not like it was coming right out
of the blue
yeah and they were going to lose the
house anyway and they probably were
so there's no reason he had no reason to
[ __ ] try to kill her to protect the
house
just you know what i mean and save it
for his new girlfriend just [ __ ]
stupid
now he's gonna spend the rest of his
life in prison and his [ __ ] kids and
his wife are dead his ex-wife and dad
yeah
and his kids look like they loved him so
it didn't make any [ __ ] sense
yeah it was like the stupidest [ __ ] ever
i mean and the thing about i have to say
too that the girlfriend nicole
was also kind of a piece of [ __ ] i don't
think that she knew
i don't think that she knew he was gonna
kill them
but she for sure i mean because they
pulled like all her computer records and
all her phone records and everything
like that like after i'm surprised she
didn't get charged with anything like
obstructing justice or anything because
she totally like lied to the police for
a little while
but she was she was googling stuff like
um no i mean one of the crew well
uh marrying your mistress she was like
looking for wedding dresses [ __ ] like
that well she was a home director
yeah she she googled do people hate
amber frye who was the um the mistress
of
scott peterson who killed lacey peterson
that was another guy that killed his
pregnant wife
do people hate amber fry and she also
looked up amber frye
book deal so she's like looking to make
some money out of this [ __ ]
damn it's like so she was like a [ __ ]
viper also maybe there was some [ __ ] and
then she was recording that after or
before
the murders um after i guess it was
after
she wanted to know if she could make
money off if she could make money off of
like hey i'm the mystery she knew he was
gonna kill him though
i don't think so either but i do think
that she's
a [ __ ] and that she's like looking
to i think she was just to make money
out of it
i think it was a typical typical other
woman type situation you know i mean
[ __ ] she wanted that man and uh
she knew that the [ __ ] ex-wife that
the first wife was gonna go
but i don't think she knew he was gonna
kill her kill him yeah i think maybe
they had talked about
that they were gonna separate yeah and i
think there's no telling
what he told her you know in in person
she might have thought that they were
going to move into that house together
and that and that that house just have
totally paid for and that he was able to
[ __ ]
cover all the bills and that you know
that he was for all she knew he was
financially very successful
because on on the surface it looked like
he was that's what i mean and that's
what's like really creepy about this
[ __ ] documentary is because because
it's told so much through like
you know shenan's like facebook like all
her videos and stuff like that they look
like
they're just perfect yeah life they look
like they look like high-end high-income
but then you find out like that all this
horrible [ __ ] was going on like under
the surface so you can't like trust
anybody it's like it was a good episode
it was really good i for it was weird
because like we started watching it and
i thought it was like a documentary
series but it's not it's just like a
standalone documentary it's like
it's like an hour and a half oh yeah
it's like an update no no
so yeah that's what i thought too
because that's kind of netflix's thing
is
they they do like you know six eight
episodes whatever like about one crime
so they can kind of go into it
but now like i said i will say it's a
good documentary it's a good like
introduction to the case and like i said
it's super creepy the way
that she put it together the fact that
it was all like this
footage um because as i said you can see
you know the [ __ ] happening like i was
in real time and how creepy it is
that you never know like what people's
what's really going on like in people's
lives like because everything just seems
like this facade
and one of the creepiest things too was
that
when um after shanann and the girls like
disappeared or said they claimed and he
did not call the cops um
shanann had a friend who was worried
about her because shenan had just come
home
like from a from the six-week trip like
the night before like at 2 am and her
friend had dropped her off at the house
because her flight had been delayed or
whatever
and then like that night chris killed
her and then the next day
um he was like oh this he went like she
went on
they went on a play date or something
like that and the friend looks in the
garage and sees shanann's car in there
and it still has the car seats in it and
she's like yeah dude you're full of [ __ ]
and it's like she was supposed to go to
the doctor today and call the doctor's
office and she didn't show up
so the friend was like i'm calling the
cops and [ __ ]
chris told her not to but then of course
she did anyway because
you know that friend was a [ __ ] hero
and um then they go to the [ __ ]
neighbor's house because the neighbor
had cameras all over his [ __ ] house
and he had caught
um chris like parking his truck in a
weird place and like
loading something you couldn't tell it
was a body or anything because it was
real sketch like sketchy looking
sandra said sandra said chris and that
girlfriend were going to get an
apartment together they were going to
live in that house
yeah because like i said i don't think i
think they were behind on the more i'm
not entirely sure like maybe someone can
look at it but i don't think that
she's saying that she thinks that he
didn't want to pay that [ __ ] child
support
for three kids but really i mean he had
a job
he didn't make a whole lot of money but
you know they can only take so much from
him if you don't have the money they
can't take much for me if they don't
have anything i don't know
that's what i mean it's colorado
colorado i don't know what the laws are
there but you know you can only pay what
you can pay
i mean even before like the stupid thing
is that apparently
i mean looking from all their like um
because they pulled like all their text
messages and everything like that
between
um chris and his wife like before like
all the arguments they had and all this
other kind of stuff
apparently when she got pregnant again
um
she according to her she was telling a
friend she's like you know chris said he
wanted another baby he like he wanted a
son
she's like but then i get pregnant and
then he's like i don't want it
you know what i mean like he basically
told her i don't want it like you need
to get rid of it
and she was like wigging out he knew he
was leaving that's what i mean and it's
like so
as i said it's just this dude is just
another creepy thing too is that like
when
um the cop first got there like you know
when
supposedly shanann had disappeared they
asked him they were asking him like do
you know you know where
where she is and like what happened and
stuff and he's like answering no i don't
know
and he was like smirking almost like he
couldn't like hide it
yeah like no i don't know where she is
yeah yeah it was so
his emotions were all wrong from what it
seemed like yeah it's like he didn't i
mean
they were he wasn't under any stress he
didn't wasn't no no he wasn't like where
are they where are they you know he
wasn't like that
which is what a normal person would be
able to find him like if your wife and
kids was missing you'd be like
wigging out like where the [ __ ] are you
jumping in the car looking for him right
and it's like the fact that he was just
like nope i don't know where they are
because he knew they weren't coming back
yeah but uh horrifying yeah it's
horrifying
yeah now um what was i gonna say i was
gonna say something more about him
just odd [ __ ] about him that doesn't
matter i'll remember
yeah sandra was saying i think chris
thought he had more time to get rid of
evidence and get an alibi but shenan's
friend came
in between he didn't expect the police
to show up that early
yeah maybe that's what it was because
the friend whose name was also nicole i
was watching another video about this
earlier and they called her good nicole
and
nicole because that was the girlfriend's
the husband's girlfriend's name too
but um yeah she was just like she knew
something was suspicious like
right from the top and she jumped and
she was just like no man this isn't
right i remember what i was gonna say
about the relationship between the the
new girlfriend and the old girlfriend
he had been with the old with the wife
for about eight years i think it was
eight years yeah
and like i said he was [ __ ] kind of
beta
she looked like she kind of bossed him
around a little bit i kind of have a
feeling that
he met the new girlfriend and i think
she kind of looked up to him or
something in a way which made him feel
like
more masculine he's like i'm gonna be
with this one that's what i think
happened
maybe and then he started getting back
in shape
yeah yeah i saw his weights that
[ __ ] didn't have that like 120
pounds
i thought you'd comment yeah i was like
dude that's like 120 pounds on that bar
if that says i really like though i have
to say that i really love that the cop
the male cop like when they first
brought him in they're like um
you're probably cheating on your wife
because you suddenly like you got all
into fitness and everything
which is like i said that doesn't
necessarily mean that but that is a very
very common thing
that people that are cheating on their
significance well he saw her at work
yeah and then you know what i mean he
starts aspiring to that
i think that she pursued him
yeah and i like yeah he got an ego boost
from it yeah
i'm gonna tell you
she treated most likely all right the
pattern knowing how guys
are she treated him better than the old
wife
that's probably what happened yeah so
he's like i got to be with this one
because he's not he didn't seem to be a
very strong personality he couldn't see
through things he didn't
like i said he's an npc yeah he just
seemed
he didn't seem terribly right not real
bright and then he
he started he doesn't really think this
through he's like well i'll just i'll
just kill this family
it'll be all right yeah what the [ __ ]
you coming what are you talking about
dude
he's an idiot yeah you're a [ __ ]
idiot even if you have a slim chance of
getting caught and going to prison
you're going to take that slim chance
for [ __ ] go to life in prison
when you can just do what everybody else
does just divorce your [ __ ] wife
divorce your [ __ ] wife man with the
you don't need to kill her
and they have the kids you're gonna kill
the kids crap you need your ass beat
you need your ass beat bad well i don't
know what people will think about what
are they gonna think of you when your
[ __ ] wife comes up missing
and your kids come up missing they're
gonna know you did it even if they don't
know
even if they can't prove it they're
gonna do it man you did that well like i
said
it's like i don't know like you know the
the exact statistic but every time a
woman gets murdered like that
nine times out of ten it is usually
their husband or their ex-husband or
their boyfriend or something like that
it's almost always that
yeah and they dig through the past and
there's a long paper trail of all kinds
of [ __ ] problems
and a bunch of motives that this dude
might have to get rid of to
knock the wife off yeah i mean one thing
i will say because
i i kind of feel like you know even
though this was directed by a woman but
i will say that they made shenan
i don't know if they made her look bad
but they did make her look kind of
needy and obnoxious a little bit and i
don't know
because from what i read of her like
when i kind of read more about the case
you know she was kind of a little bit
obnoxious i guess where she was
she was just real bossy she was just
kind of one of those like go-getter type
women um
but i feel like she was a lot nicer than
they portrayed her
in this world like she was a bad person
no she wasn't
just i think the new woman treated him
better that's why he did it
yeah but like you said he's an npc he
had mental problems though he took that
[ __ ] too far
that's what i mean that is like a
sociopathic
and i mean for him to just stand there
and be like no i don't know where they
are and then he's just like smirking at
the cops
[ __ ] that guy he's a piece of [ __ ]
you're crazy god it's a lizard
yeah yeah i i can't [ __ ] i mean
that's just so [ __ ] dumb it's
something missing in him something
missing in that dude
yeah yeah i mean it's not normal
and another thing too that i found out
and i was like oh that's really nice too
that he actually killed all three of
them but then he tried to
posthumously blame it on his wife like
oh you know
she was killing the kids and i just like
blacked out with rage and killed her
to save them or whatever and then it's
like then it came to light later that he
had actually tried to kill the kids
first like he tried to strangle them or
smother them
and then he thought he had killed them
and then he went into the master bedroom
and killed shanann and but then the
little girls got up
yeah you know what i mean so they were
still alive and so he puts
he puts her body in the [ __ ] car and
then puts the little girls in there
alive
and takes him out to the [ __ ] oil
field [ __ ] yeah and then smothers the
kids and
stuffs them into the [ __ ] he had the
dead mommy in the back or something yeah
he's a real piece of work man and the
kids were just like is mommy okay what's
the matter with her
it's like this is [ __ ] horrifying
yeah [ __ ] horrifying make your skin
crawl
yeah i mean the only thing the only
thing kind of close
is a couple of cases that i've heard
about
where a guy kills the whole family a
family annihilator that's what they call
that
which one that's that's what they called
that type of family
usually they commit suicide though yeah
usually they commit to so this was kind
of a rare
stay alive though yeah and then usually
it's kind of like an honor killing
he's got this big [ __ ] house
and uh he's doing thing quote-unquote
quote the right way end quote
you know what i mean and he's real
[ __ ] kind of uptight
and he's got to be the [ __ ] main
breadwinner he's one of those kind of
guys
and he loses his job he can't [ __ ]
hide it from everybody
and his status in the family is gonna be
diminished
and um they're gonna have to [ __ ]
leave the house and go to [ __ ]
cheaper quarters until he can find
and he can't he can't deal with it he
can't go with that he's a guy who once
he has something he can't let it go he
can only move up he can't move down
yeah so what he does is he like
rationalizes to himself that i have to
put this family
out of their misery yeah so he usually
ambushes them and [ __ ]
quick coup de gras like gunshot wounds
to the head don't even know it's coming
and then he wraps everything up and
burns the house down then it kills
himself that's usually what happens
something like that
one dude [ __ ] just killed him left
left them all out left [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know kind of left them out like
they were
he left him in positions of honor and
[ __ ] and then vanished yeah they didn't
find him for [ __ ] decades
they found him as a very old man later
where he had kind of
kind of just survived yeah weird you
know
there's some guys that just can't deal
with [ __ ]
loss of face kind of like something
it's almost kind of like something that
you might see happen in japan
where a guy commits suicide because he
loses his job that kind of deal
i mean the [ __ ] up thing about that is
that
is that their wife and kids at that
stage are just part of
their ego like it's something that's
propping their ego up it's almost like
they don't consider them as like full
people
no because it's kind of like you know
well oh this is part of my image my
image is collapsing so i have to like
get rid of them it's like you know you
didn't ask them
if like you know it's like maybe we know
we can move to another place it'll be
fine all this other kind of stuff i
think the dudes that do that are not
fully [ __ ] people you know i mean
they're kind of lizard-like yeah i like
this dude
kind of npc-ish and um
when they lose control of the situation
they just [ __ ] try to abort
everything
yeah you know what i mean it's like oh
well i can't
if i lose my job we'll lose the house
and then we'll be poor
and my kids will i'll have to take them
out of private school and they'll have
to go to regular school and they'll have
a bad upbringing and
they won't be up to my standards and all
this [ __ ] will be substandard and
you know if so you know we we have to
end all
this and that's the thinking yeah weird
it is very weird
yeah it's i don't understand that
mindset at all like i said because
you're taking all of their
choice away maybe maybe [ __ ] would work
out all right you don't yeah yeah it
would
it probably would it's just too uptight
right um he's really
super set in his ways he's doing exactly
what he was told what he thinks is the
right thing
and it's a big kind of like honor
killing and here's the weird thing is he
sees the families as kind of like
extensions of himself yeah that's what i
meant that there are things that he
created
yeah and that in order to protect them
he has to now kill them
yeah he has to protect them from a bad
future
yeah but like i said it's like something
you'd see in japan where a guy kills
himself because he loses his job
and the family is dishonored that type
of deal yeah people get too wrapped up
in that get wrapped up that [ __ ]
well and the thing about it is most
people are living their own lives they
don't give a [ __ ] about you losing your
jobs
no one's talking about you nobody's
looks like you know what i mean just do
your own [ __ ] but it kind of comes from
cultures where everything is set on
rails and that everything happens
according to a plan
yeah in other words like a a ritualized
or a stylized lifestyle
yeah and those are pretty much gone and
if they ever existed
i don't not sure they act actually ever
existed
i mean i kind of feel like this this
dude chris watts had a little bit of
that because like i said it seemed like
his image was more important than
yeah his family's lives were like he
didn't want to look like a bad guy he
didn't want to look like hey i'm the
[ __ ] that left my pregnant wife
yeah for another one a bad guy so i'm
gonna kill my family right which makes
him look like an even worse guy because
he is also a [ __ ] idiot
yeah clearly yeah and they you know
they they had all oh another thing too
that i forgot to
say that nicole the the bad nicole
girlfriend
um another thing that she googled was
can
can the police uh like pull up your
deleted text messages or something like
that so it's like these were not [ __ ]
master criminals that we're talking
about here they were like googling
pretty much like how to do this than the
other thing like
am i gonna yeah it's like it's it's
stupid but yes
the the thing that pissed me off the
most was the [ __ ] that she googled about
amber fry and like the book deal and
everything like that because that whole
like [ __ ] lacy peterson murder
i was like yeah stay classy chick i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened to her
like i said i don't know why she didn't
get in trouble
because i mean i don't think she knew
anything about the murder but like i
said
they can do like for uh
obstructing justice that kind of stuff i
mean i don't know why she didn't get in
trouble but whatever
what are you gonna do but yeah so if you
guys haven't watched it it's a really
good documentary like i said they do
leave a lot of stuff
out um as i discovered when i
went digging into the case a little bit
more it's weird because it's like really
good documentary but
some of the stuff they left out i think
should have been
put in there you know what i'm saying
because it you know was germane to the
case
but um you know it's a minor criticism
other than that i really liked it and
like i said i liked the
the more found footage-y kind of way
that they did it it kind of came across
really cool
but um that all you have to say i just
say [ __ ] that dude
well yeah i don't think anyone's gonna
argue with you on that score
somebody said in there that [ __ ]
the dog the daughters the one daughter
saw him
saw the dad kill the other daughter and
then she goes you're gonna do that to me
and then he killed her
yeah that's some bad [ __ ] i couldn't
even
i couldn't even do that to one of my
cats that's what i was saying it's like
how the [ __ ] can you do that so like a
little kid that's like
like daddy no like it has a
consciousness is related to you
god damn you you have to be a [ __ ]
cold ass [ __ ]
uh you can't read too much into it
you're dealing with a person that has
some kind of mental [ __ ] problem
yeah and that they don't that they're
like a lizard
some kind of brain [ __ ] problem to
where
uh yeah i mean and i [ __ ] i come from
a background i totally understand
dudes fighting each other to the death
on some kind of [ __ ] japanese island
burning each other
[ __ ] the crisps with [ __ ]
flamethrowers and stuff i can totally
relate to that
you know but i can't relate to anything
like this
that's yeah that's what i mean it's like
this is like yeah that would horrify
every [ __ ] soldier i ever [ __ ]
served with to be like whoa
and then those same dudes might be able
to press a button and drop
fire down on other people's [ __ ]
families while they're sleeping in their
houses you know i mean like they could
do that
but they couldn't [ __ ] do that to
their own kids
they'd have they'd have a hard time
doing that to somebody else's kids you
know what i mean
yeah even the enemies kids up close well
up close like it's easier to move from
there
and then launch a missile that's very
different yeah because you almost feel
like you're like removed
you're kind of removed from it you're
just doing orders and you're just
[ __ ] designating something to what
the higher ups told you to do and
hey you know this is my job take that
rocket
but yeah if they made them like get up
in their faces you're right go down
there and go kill that family go
strangle that little girl
those dudes couldn't do that no i would
hope not yeah
i mean most normal people would not be
able to do that no [ __ ] way
well here's another thing even the nazis
couldn't do that for the most part
that's what those concentration camps
were all about they put them in there
and had capos do it who were
german criminals yeah and then in the
end they were going to kill those
criminals that's who was running those
death camps well like i said that was a
very like industrialized way so
like is so it was away from it yeah a
way of like removing themselves from the
equation
and the death camps weren't even in
germany they were in other people's
countries they were in poland yeah
so you know they were really trying to
distance the germans from it
that was because they had these
einsteins group and before that who were
special action groups they were just
they were just um
recruited from regular german policemen
they kind of militarized them
and sent them into eastern europe to
slaughter families
you know usually captured jewish
families from the jewish sectors of
whatever town they took
they'd dig a big pit shoot them with
rifles
and then bury them well it didn't work
because the guys started blowing their
own
heads off you know what i mean because
they were they couldn't
to couldn't take it yeah you know these
are nazis they couldn't take it
so that's why all those death camps were
made yeah
because their own people couldn't do
that so it makes you wonder
what kind of [ __ ] can strangle
his own kids like that
that's what i'm saying and the creepiest
thing to me like about this
was that the dude he didn't have a
criminal record he didn't have he seemed
completely normal
yeah and he seemed like like he just
seemed like a regular like bland
upper middle middle-class white dude
yeah you seem totally [ __ ] just like
regular
regular plain ass [ __ ] and
that's why i told him i said look you
can't trust anybody yeah well no
holy [ __ ] well just that dude was an
anomaly
and you never know though that's what
i'm saying you never know it's like just
the most normal [ __ ] milk toast
[ __ ] walking in the street just
oh i'm gonna strangle my wife and kids
yeah and then how do you go
and you know what i'm gonna do after i
get this done i'm gonna get me some
[ __ ] after this
yeah that's what he's thinking and the
fact that he actually thought
that like and that he thought that that
girl that the girlfriend was gonna i
mean she like i said she sucked too
anyway but yeah yeah i'm like i'd be
like you killed him didn't you
yeah he'd be like he's like yeah come
here baby yeah
no yeah you know eventually he would
have told him he was you know
i killed my wife and kids for you
eventually they would have gone to that
he would he would have [ __ ] spilled
it and if he had got away with it and
it's like if she pissed him off he would
have killed her too
yeah she would have ratted him out
eventually god damn
she probably would have ratted him out
as soon as he said that just [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] like i said you can't
just normal looking dudes walking down
the street one day and all of a sudden
terrifying but yeah so it's on uh
netflix if you want to watch it at least
in the us i don't know if it is in other
countries but
uh yeah it's like a fascinating case and
like i said i don't
it was like a huge like media sensation
and somehow
uh i somehow i didn't really know
anything about it so i didn't really
know where it was going i mean like i
said i kind of like figured when i saw
that [ __ ] smirk that i was like oh he
totally did it but um
but you know i didn't know the outcome
so it was like kind of cool but
uh you know to watch like watch the
whole thing unfold because i didn't
know exactly what was gonna happen um
but yeah it's good like i said they
leave a lot of stuff out so
if you're interested in the case you
probably want to go and like read a
whole bunch of other [ __ ] and all the
footage
that they have that they put in the
documentary like all of the um his
polygraph
tests like all his uh you know all the
body cam footage and all that
um the entire [ __ ] is on youtube so if
you want to watch like the whole like
unedited
uh all the body cam footage all the you
know him getting interviewed his
polygraph and stuff you can see the
whole thing it's all on youtube i
saw it earlier today all right so uh we
will
uh kind of taper this off i guess yeah
and uh we'll be back tomorrow talking
about another movie
uh which we've actually already seen so
i'm gonna
i'm kind of excited to talk about this
one because it's like a horror movie and
i really really dug it
uh but yeah so we'll be back tomorrow at
uh 3 p.m eastern standard time like
usual
with another live matinee so bye